hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
today's topic is about radio frequency
and speaker cables audiophiles are
always worried about rf and noise
rf actually is a very very complicated
topic and
it's surprising that audiophiles will
latch on to it
without understanding uh you know the
complexities of it and true relevance of
it to audio
anyway i'm doing this video because uh
there's an online
video published by danny from
gr research who normally does decent
videos good videos actually on
crossover design and speaker mods but
he's also started doing some videos on
speaker cables and he did demonstration
that raised
quite a few eyebrows and then
that sort of came and went but he seems
to be doubling down on it and i thought
we uh try to replicate his experiment
and
uh and see if we get the same results he
has so let me first show you
his video and i've sped this up 50
so we get through it faster let's watch
the video that i did months ago and
let's talk about that and what the
purpose was in that video
so what i did was i took an old receiver
and it had an old connection on the back
that you could hook up an antenna to for
amrf in reception
and back then back in the day when we
when we used tuners and receivers
um there'd be a connection on the back
that we'd hook up what's called a t-top
antenna which would just be two wires
run side by side and it would go up the
wall and then split into a t and that
worked really well as an antenna
and the purpose of the whole thing was
to illustrate that your cables
especially your speaker cables and it's
every cable in your system
can be or is either a good antenna
meaning that it's picking up
everything it's picking up rf noise
which is radio frequency interference
it's picking up
electromagnetic interference which could
be generated from your power supplies
from your gear or
lighting in your room and all kinds of
things or it could be a filter
and it can be rejecting those things so
in order to illustrate that whole
situation
i hooked up different types of speaker
cable to the fm receptacles there
and of course a side-by-side zip cord
regular speaker cable
was a great antenna and the signal
strength on the meter
just because it went this way for you it
shot right up good signal strength
and some of the ones that were twisted
uh would go up a little bit
it was still you know there was some
filtering going on in there because of
twisting and then we hooked up one of
these that was a
multiple strand braided cable where the
conductors are all cross crossing over
on each other
anyone didn't get into all so it was
it's the type of cable that we consider
to be
a filter and so the flat earth guys came
out of the woodworks and tried to prove
that
what i was doing was invalid and you're
not showing anything other than
whether or not a speaker cable can be
used as an antenna or not it has nothing
to do with audio
and all that stuff that's in the air it
doesn't affect the audio signal and
all kinds of crazy stuff
so yeah we did that there are many
arguments against
what he says but today i want to do
something different
as he said he took a fm tuner and
uh hooked up speaker wires to it and
showed the signal strength meter as is
tuned on one frequency
and that the signal strength changed
with different cables hooked up to it
and that's indeed true that's what an
antenna is it's a piece of wire can be
an antenna
and different configuration of wires
acts differently as
as antennas and the question is is it
relevant and was that test correct
one of the things he did was that he
even though he's trying to emulate what
a
stereo system is we don't use a speaker
cable hanging in the air hooked up to an
fm receiver
we hooked that up to speaker and an
amplifier
and that has important characteristics
so let's uh
look at the test setup that i have here
try and replicate what he did but much
more properly
let me go full screen um i have a
cheap zip cord which he says is you know
it's the worst thing is the problem type
of cable
and it's indeed it's not twisted uh this
is one end of it just sitting over here
um the other end of it is over there i
don't want to move it because when you
move wires you actually change
the way they act like an antenna but
basically the other end
one connections hooked up the ground and
the other one hooked up to the
center pin of the signal and goes to
that spectrum analyzer
it's hard to see the spectrum analyzer
over there in my tektronix
uh scope but uh we can bring it over
here
and uh look at it in our browser
uh let me go in here and
so you also see the same thing let me uh
turn off the menus so we can see the
whole screen so
basically all these pulses are various
fm stations that are
around here and they're carriers and and
sidebands in there
so indeed we see that my piece of wire
is acting like an antenna and it's
picking up a lot of uh stations so in
theory is right and as i said
wires are antennas uh but look what
happens here i have a
yamaha cheap yamaha 100 120 dollar
integrated amplifier uh watch the
display and see what happens when i hook
this up to the
yamaha amplifier
did you notice what happened massive
filtration
of the uh carriage we still have some
left
and i'll explain that in a second what
is the case but
uh look at how much lower the apple
juice is i'll go ahead and
take them out so you can see their
effect in reverse
look at how much they jump back up so
clearly we have a fly in his example
right yuck you have to test the system
as it's used
not as a component by itself in a
different application
yes if you wanted to make different
wires as antennas
this is a better antenna than some other
wires but
that doesn't mean that is representing
what we do
and of course in a real use the other
end of this
will actually hook up to a speaker which
also acts as a load
and by the way in stuff inside of a
speaker it can be an antenna or it can
be something that filters out
rf it's totally unknown um in fm
frequencies the wavelengths are very
short so even something this small
like the connector at the end of the
cable can actually be an antenna so even
if you have the rest of the wire
twisted and you know it's perfect
isolator uh
insulator to rf um the connectors can
pick up stuff to crossover components
anyway so we still have this i've got
this hooked up and uh
you know somebody may argue hey you know
you're still picking up rf i am as i
mentioned
you know everything's there's still
things that pick up rf signals
and that's a very sensitive instrument
so we're looking here
uh and there's a vertical scale in here
and uh i've got a cursor up here that
shows our
uh amplitude of these signals and it's
hovering between
depending on which station it it grabs
on to 52 db here 57 db
the scale here is an rf scale called dpm
mn stands for milliwatt i did a video a
couple days ago on on
decibels and in audio we
use decibels relative to a voltage here
rf people use uh power so
one milliwatt is zero db but these
signals are minus 60
db so quite a bit weaker than every one
milliwatt how much weaker
well we can take one of them like -57
and put that in here go ahead put minus
57
little online calculator dbm and find
out what that is
so this is actually tells us how many
milliwatts we have
so if this had been zero zero zero one
it would have been one microwatt as it
is
it's two nanowatt is my my reading is
correct
so two billionth of a watt
is getting picked up by this wire in the
form of
rf clearly you can't hear that because
even one middle one will be hard to hear
uh let alone you know two nanowatts so
these are very very very small numbers
as it should be there's a transmitter
miles and miles away how much power do
you think is going to induce into a
speaker cable it's not going to be the
kind of power that you can possibly
imagine but somebody could argue that
hey this signal
when it goes through the amplifier maybe
through feedback it goes back
and goes to the input and it gets fully
amplified
all right that's a stretch but let's say
it is a
typical uh amplifier has about 29 db
gain so let's say it's 30 so instead of
minus 57
we'll have minus 27 and we convert that
so now we're two microwatts of power
so that rf signal has been reduced down
to two
microwatts even after being fully
amplified by this amplifier
two microwatts coming out and at what
frequency is it coming out
uh oop
uh 99 megahertz in this case a hundred
megahertz
we can't hear a hundred killers how the
heck we're gonna hear a hundred megas
now danny goes on to some fantasy logic
where he says look
there are other cable manufacturers who
say that cables filter rf
therefore rf filtering must be a thing
it's like no
all of you in the same business of
promoting things that don't work
the fact that you you know wrap arms
around each other doesn't make
the faulty logic true yes all of you
claim things and by the way none of you
demonstrated like i am properly
demonstrating in a real system
you stick a cable up in the air with an
antenna with an fm dial you tell me
that's proof
no you got to show me that my system as
configured as we use it
actually has rf in it and that rf is
coming out of my speaker and somehow
it's audible
now there is an element of truth to all
these things
and that's what people tend to believe
these because they um
you've probably heard stories and you
may have had a system where all of a
sudden it seems to be picking up the
local stations
through your stereo how does that happen
typically that's
am stations not fm and because of the
modulation scheme is very simple
um that am carrier can actually
the am signal can get coupled on your
input signal especially
especially if you have live sound and
use a microphone
cables are long they act like good am
station
am frequency wavelengths and they pick
up that and microphone
amplifiers have very high gain and that
could be amplified
and then a simple junction in the
transistor can actually demodulate am
and turn it into the sound that's riding
on that high frequency
fm station am station so the carry
itself obviously is not audible
but if we demodulate that pull the sound
out of it just like an am radio would
then that becomes audible so
that can happen but again the
circumstances have to be
just perfect for that to happen it has
to be that it's am station not fm by the
way if i do this test in half
am and i plug in this cable it just all
you know go down to nothing because it's
very easy to shunt am frequency is a
much lower frequency
and but even if that happens then you'll
know it there's a specific thing while
you you'll hear
station in there it's never a case that
there's high frequencies
megahertz go in here and they spit out
some halo round music that makes it have
less detail
or have it be you know less analog like
more edgy you know more space what have
you
none of that can happen with rf signals
it just violates the most simple
principles of
what an rf signal is we'd go nuts if
that was happening to us we obviously
can't hear it it's all the way around
it's
all around us but we don't hear it and
audio circuits are
horrible at amplifying you know
frequencies this high and fm frequencies
you have to build proper rf circuits
for them to have any performance at this
high frequency so
bottom line these people always
talk about a component and with a hand
wavy and maybe a crude demonstration
like we saw from
danny but they don't show you an
end-to-end system
they claim that the end-to-end system is
impacted the stereo that we have the
sound that comes out of the speaker
but where are the speaker measurements
danny knows how to measure speakers
he's got the setup measure now he says
well i can't show you
those measurements tough luck then you
then you don't have any objective
reliable data
we can't just trust your word when
you're in the next breath you're gonna
go sell us uh
speaking cables so bottom line is
there's an element of truth to to all
this
wires do pick up radio frequencies
they're sort of an antenna they're
horrible antennas but
they are antennas nevertheless but once
you put a speaker and a low impedance
load of a
amplifier and low impedance load of a
speaker
a lot of it gets shunted out and what's
left over
it is so low in amplitude and so low in
power
that it just you know except for
contrived and specific examples that i
gave
they simply do not degrade your audio
why do people hear improvements
because the brain just likes to do that
you know i give you a gable and i tell
you all these things if you're convinced
that what i'm telling you is the truth
then you plug it in and then you focus
more you pay more attention to your
music
then all of a sudden you hear the
separation between the instruments
better you hear a lower noise floor the
veil gets lifted all the classic things
your brain loves to manufacture things
you know we dream about
nonsense stuff at night so there's no
limit to
what the brain can manufacture and
the only valid test for listening is
to do a blind test do it 10 times in a
row
of some loved ones swap cables one for
the other
and see if you get eight out of ten
right anything less than that
probability of guessing is too high
we can't accept that but you know 10
tesla with a speaker cable
somebody like danny should be able to do
it in in
five minutes right get his somebody
works there or his wife or somebody
just with his back towards the system
swap the cables put a towel on him so
you can't see the speaker wires
he knows how to shoot videos leave the
camera running
you know we trust him go ahead use use
the camera
have a log that we can see on the camera
but he can't
eight out of ten times simple thing you
know if you don't believe any of the
instrumentation
just do that if you're unwilling to do a
test where you don't know which cable is
plugged in
and therefore you know all the you know
clear differences
are not audible to you and you can't do
things with the proper instrumentation a
proper example like i'm trying to do
with a real setup and understanding of
the technology
how does it work how could i have caused
problems none of this knowledge is
within the scope of what he's talking
about
he's just going in a classic gut
intuition of i've been to audio shows
and i've heard cables make a difference
therefore there must be a difference no
you know i can
play the identical systems 10 times in a
row and ask you if i swap cables you
will tell me sometimes i swap cables
even though i haven't touched a thing
guaranteed guaranteed i mean there's
i'll put money on the table that he will
fail
to pass any blind test whatsoever of
these speaking gables so
that's what science expects if you're
going to write a paper to audio
engineering society
or acoustic society of america they're
respected
organizations that's what they'll ask
for they'll say
show me some measurements that rf is a
problem in here and do a simple control
test but you don't know which is which
um do it on yourself do it on a few
other people
you'll be a hero he'll get a medal like
you would not believe he can prove that
speaker cable's this simply that if you
just twist some buyers
and stick them in all of a sudden
there's all this improvement i can't
tell you how famous it will become if it
just passes some simple tests and writes
a paper
publishes to aes it passes peer review
he'll be famous but now he wants to do a
video and appeal to
you and i but we know better and
engineers do understand these things um
he has experience designing crossovers
and speakers but doesn't seem like he
has any professional experience
education
in this field so he's just guessing like
a layman he's fallen prey to the same
thing
anyway i'm not a fan of doing this type
of video
where somebody says somebody something
online and
you know and i'll go say the verse but
in this case i thought it's a useful
topic to talk about rf and what have you
and
hopefully you find it useful okay
give me some feedback let me know what
you think of videos like this
and see you in the next video bye-bye